[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about a very
controversial topic in the Dragon Ball
super fandom and by that I mean that we
will be talking about how the universe
six Saiyans and Kalifa and kale in
particular have been able to get so much
stronger so quickly I mean we've all
seen it the power of universe 6 Saiyans
and kale and cauliflower in particular
has grown so quickly that they can now
keep up with Goku and apparently they
can even beat him in a fight while fuses
kefla
even while goku is using super saiyan
blue with Kaioken how is it possible
that these universe 6 Saiyans have
increased their power and battle
capabilities so dramatically in such a
short period of time it took Goku from
the beginning of Dragonball until the
climax of the frieza saga on Namek in
Dragon Ball Z to first turn into a Super
Saiyan we then had to wait all the way
until the climax of the cell saga for
Gohan to become the first Saiyan to
reach Super Saiyan 2 and Goku manages to
achieve Super Saiyan 3 after years of
vigorous training before he can use it
during the Majin Buu saga now I've seen
quite a few fans online complaining
about Kalin Khalifa being able to grow
so quickly with Khalifa reaching Super
Saiyan and Super Saiyan 2 and blowing
through the different grades or stages
of these transformations in a very short
period of time and also with Cale being
able to tame her berserk form
unbelievably quickly let's not forget
that the entire tournament of power is
supposed to take place within only 48
minutes and yet kale and cauliflower
are just breezing through all these
forms and power-ups that took the
universe seven Saiyans years to reach in
some cases so in this video we are going
to be addressing this controversy and
offering some explanation for why Kalin
Khalifa have been able to grow so
quickly by the way I just want to say
that here on the channel we've been
getting
suddenly more support for our Dragon
Ball super content so I want to give you
a big thank you for that if you enjoy
these videos and want to see more be
sure to leave a like to let me know and
if you are new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell there are two quick
points to keep in mind that could
potentially explain some of the reason
why kefla was able to beat Super Saiyan
blue Goku one is the fact that Goku
after just having fought jiren a short
time earlier is still trained and far
below 100% strength and the other is
that Kael possesses the berserk
Super Saiyan power that is different
from the power of ordinary super safe
many have assumed that Kael strength in
her berserk form can be compared to
broli because his legendary Super Saiyan
form is so similar to kales berserk form
but because Broly is technically not
canon kales power could theoretically be
far greater than Broly at this point
nevertheless I agree that it does seem
outlandish that the Saiyans of universe
6 have been getting stronger so quickly
and many fans have said that this is
just plot convenience pure and simple
and while I am sure that plot
convenience is definitely a part of it
since it wouldn't be very fun for us to
watch the universe 6 saying struggling
for years in order to catch up to the
universe 7 Saiyans believe it or not
there are logical reasons as to why
Khalif law kale and Kaabah are growing
so much faster than to the universe 7
sayings in order to explain these
reasons I will use real-world examples
of similar things actually happening in
real life and while I can't say that
these reasons explain everything and
that plot convenience doesn't also play
a part the reasons I give you just might
make you feel a bit different about the
rapid growth that we've been seeing from
the universe 6 and especially
cauliflower and kale the first real-life
example I want to talk about is what is
known as the four-minute mile back in
the 1950s it was considered impossible
for a human being to run the distance of
a mile in less than
four minutes while many athletes had
gotten close to running a mile in four
minutes no one had succeeded in breaking
that barrier during an official
competition it got to the point that
many coaches sports experts and even
doctors said that it was simply
impossible for a human body to run a
mile in less than four minutes they even
warned that trying to do it could cause
serious physical damage to your body and
then one day in 1954 an athlete by the
name of Roger Bannister broke the
barrier and ran a mile in just a few
seconds under four minutes within a week
of Roger Bannister breaking the record
five other runners also did it within a
year fifty-four athletes from around the
world broke the barrier and only a few
years later even high school track and
field runners have begun to break the
four-minute barrier so how was this
possible for decades if not centuries
people believed it was physically
impossible to break this barrier and
then suddenly a ton of people are doing
it but that's just it as soon as the
first person succeeded as soon as Roger
Bannister showed the world that it could
be done that it was possible other
athletes were inspired to push
themselves and they also succeeded they
broke through the mental barrier of what
they thought was possible and suddenly
they were achieving the impossible the
same logic can be applied to Dragon Ball
super the universe 7 Saiyans didn't have
anyone else to show them what was
possible when Goku became a Super Saiyan
he was the first Super Saiyan any of our
main characters had ever seen before
that only legends told of the existence
of Super sands but no one knew it was
truly possible until they saw it with
their own eyes the universe seven
Saiyans essentially stumbled upon new
forms and transformations as a result of
extreme training or extremely powerful
emotions like rage however until
extraordinary threats forced them to
train so hard or put them in a situation
where their emotions took over they had
no concept of higher forms even existing
on the other hand the universe six
Saiyans saw what was possible from
watching the universe 7 Saiyans
Goku and the others were to the universe
six Saiyans what roger bannister was to
the runners of the 1950's once they knew
that new forms and transformations
existed and could be reached the
universe six sands were inspired to
strive towards reaching them to focus
directly on that goal and for this
reason they were able to attain them
more quickly the universe seven Saiyans
broke the mental barrier that told the
universe 6 Saiyans that they could only
progress so far and once these barriers
were broken everything changed
if we combine the breaking of this
mental barrier with the unique feature
of the Saiyan race which is of course
far more competitive and physically
powerful than ordinary humans then this
begins to explain why the Saiyans of
universe 6 have gotten stronger so much
quicker than the universe 7 Saiyans
the second real-life example that I
would like to bring up is the concept of
talent hot spots in a book called the
talent code author Daniel Coyle argues
that small communities of people who are
working intensely towards the same or
similar goals develop incredible talent
and skill far more quickly than they
would if they were trying to progress on
their own for example during the
Renaissance the center of this great
rebirth that took place throughout
Europe was the small Italian city of
Florence in this one city of only about
60,000 people a huge number of the
world's greatest artists appeared
including Donatello Botticelli Raphael
Michelangelo and Leonardo da Vinci along
with many others all of these incredibly
talented people were either born in or
lived in Florence during the Renaissance
so why would so many amazing artists
appear in this one place wouldn't the
law of averages suggest that such
amazing talent should be spread out
throughout Italy and the world
in the talent code the author argues
that if you have a bunch of talented
people working together in close
proximity and striving for similar goals
in this case creating incredible art
these people will learn from each other
they will compete with each other to see
who is better and through this process
all of them will be lifted up together
and they will become greater than they
could ever have been on their own if we
think back to Dragon Ball super the
universe six Saiyans came into contact
with the far stronger sands of universe
7 and they were also forced to fight
against these stronger Saiyans in
tournaments and this forced them to
prove themselves they work together to
get stronger they learn from each other
they competed with each other and they
ended up growing much faster than they
would have if they never met the
universe seven Saiyans or if they never
found a common goal to fight for
cauliflower and kale are especially
close to each other and khalifa is
always pushing kale and kale doesn't
want to disappoint khalifa so together
they keep advancing further ahead in a
way that they never could have if they
didn't have each other meeting the
universe 7 sands and being forced to
fight them in tournaments created a
talent hotspot that helped propel the
growth of the universe six Saiyans and
of course we have been seeing the fruits
of that growth during the tournament of
power now I am NOT saying that this
explains everything and I think that
people who say that plot convenience has
a lot to do with the strength of Kalifa
and kale have a legitimate argument but
I think that the ideas of the
four-minute mile and breaking barriers
along with the idea of talent hot spots
offer a compelling logical explanation
for why the universe six Saiyans have
grown so quickly please give me your
thoughts on this topic down in the
comments do you think that what I said
in this video about the four-minute mile
and talent hot spots make sense in the
context of Dragon Ball super or do you
still think that it's all about plot
convenience let me know down below I'd
love to hear from you if you enjoyed
this video leave a like to let me know
and if you're new to the channel
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bail the next Dragon Ball
super video that I am planning will be
about Goku's ultra instinct and some
very important aspects about it that I
feel a lot of people are missing
especially when I see some of the
comments on my Dragon Ball super videos
that talk about Ultra instinct
I am definitely excited for that video
but in the meantime thank you so much
for watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]